nous sommes au coeur du territoire de la
grande séduction
cinq mille personnes et une douzaine de
villages accrochés à l'acompte sur 400
km des villages éloignés l'un de l'autre
coupé du reste de la province le québec
du bout du monde avec le désir de briser
cet isolement
je pense que l'on peut se permettre de
rêver d'avoir un journée un autre qui
vont peut-être rejoindre un autre
communauté puis de rejoindre marion ce
rêve
le maire de gros mécatina avait trouvé
une façon de le réaliser avec les élus
des autres municipalités et les chefs de
deux communautés autochtones
il a vendu l'idée au gouvernement que
les normes outils commencent eux-mêmes à
construire la route c'est tout le s e
rang où je vais m'adapter à la baleine
est ce qu'elle sera en tête avec même le
nom en jeu 5 michael owen climat m puis
on relativisera vous en tout 47 millions
de dollars ont été dépensés et seuls 12
km de routes construit tout est arrêté
la route ne va nulle part un tronçon et
mutilent perdu dans la taïga
était 2006 blanc-sablon le chef-lieu de
la basse-côte-nord reçoit de la grande
visite
le premier ministre charest et trois de
ses ministres viennent d'annoncer 100
millions de dollars pour commencer à
construire la route tant rêver la route
qui va désenclaver la basse côte nord
il est rare que québec ait permis une
formule où est un pur âge une formule
comme cela c'est même très rare il faut
voir dans notre décision à nous un geste
de confiance fait mieux
la formule c'est donner la maîtrise
d'oeuvre aux municipalités et aux
communautés autochtones regroupés dans
un organisme nommé pakatan un organisme
avis pourrait mettre en oeuvre la
construction de routes
selon des normes qui serait sécuritaire
est acceptable et des normes qui vous
nous permettrait d'aller plus rapidement
que si c'était le gouvernement du québec
était le maître d'oeuvre du projet
le gouvernement donne à pakatan la
responsabilité de déterminer les
priorités car 100 millions ne suffisent
pas pour faire 400 km de routes les plus
vite et forcer les villages qui étaient
le plus à l'évidence le plus les a
laissés tessin du bus fait ça fait des
années qu'ils réclament un pont sur la
rivière pour l'aider à claret
il choisit ceux de relier certains
villages entre eu plutôt que de
prolonger la route 138 à partir de là où
s arrête à l'est de natashquan
après le pont de saint-augustin il
souhaite relier le village de harrington
harbour à la terre ferme
chevrier est à seulement 12 km avec son
aéroport et surtout l'école secondaire
pour que les enfants puissent aller à
l'école
bellamy a chez lui à tous les soirs là
les enfants ils restent toutes les
semaines à celle des preuves et des
arabes
ils sont achevés il a déjà pris le pire
étant chez eux ensuite relier la romaine
acquis gasca et finalement faire la
route entre gros mécatina était à la
baleine une route forestière en gravier
chaque village aurez ainsi accès à un
aéroport pakatan doit donc construire
petit à petit une route plus rapidement
et à moindre coût que le gouvernement un
cadeau empoisonné en 2006 avec jean
charles b avec 2
trois caisses d'autres ministres moi je
dis un même si charest mais municipalité
et toutes les autres mines suspects et
non pour les spas tease pour faire une
route d'un salaire on n'est même pas
capable de faire un chemin ministère
pourquoi qu'on me donne pas ça au
ministère des transports on était naïf
je pensais qu'on pouvait prendre des
belles puis commencer à construire puis
année de 20 ans c'est une démarche
politique était fait certainement que le
premier avec le premier ministre et avec
madame boulet peeling convenu d'un
ministère des transport régional
les autres ils ont été surpris à des
prix défiant travers que jean charest
nous annonçant millions sur 10 ans pour
construire une route en beauce conan
c'est d'impôts dans leur planification
pas de plan en effet plutôt un coup
politique orchestrée avec l'aide de la
firme d'ingénierie genivar
on est allé dans un hôtel à québec
on s'est assis on a travaillé sur un
document on oublie en aval l'aide de
deux des gens de genivar genivar venait
à ce moment-là d'engager un ancien
sous-ministre adjoint andré bossé
fraîchement retraité du ministère des
transports
c'est un jeune igor qui nous contient
peu comment organiser la rencontre du
tout parce qu'arabes ribotti avait été
soumis ni span a examiné avec thomas a
procédé
le bureau du ministre peu de saveur pour
avoir de vraies donc fait du lobbying
pour vous et gaffeur d'oubli depuis
genivar a été vendu à une firme
américaine wsp chacune des firmes qui
avait cette opportunité d'engager
quelqu'un qui connaisse un ministère qui
y voyaient un avantage l'ont fait parce
que c'est bon ce que c'est mauvais ça
des traces tronchet de la personne
appelée dès le début de l' aventure sans
appel d'offres genivar gère les travaux
pour pakatan qui n'a aucune expertise en
construction de routes
y a personne de nous autres ça va
construire h mais vous l'avez vous
aujourd'hui à peu le chemin ici les
travaux doivent débuter à saint-augustin
si le village identifié comme le plus
isolé
la priorité numéro 1 de pas kahtan al
une équipe isri il y a peu de choix de
légumes et de fruits frais sans parler
des prix ils sont tellement élevé que
les pommes se vend à l'unité et non au
kilo
ici comme dans les autres villages
l'isolément coûte cher car tout presque
arrivent par bateau comme l'essence un
bateau qui passe une fois par semaine ça
vous coûte combien faire le plein ça
nous coûte de l'argent est allé faire le
train doit être ça me coûte combien au
dos pour vraiment rempli je jamais quand
j'étais un petit peu à la fois elle va
autour de 950 de la forêt
mais le problème à saint-augustin c'est
l'absence de ponts cela complique le
quotidien des villageois installés de
chaque côté de la rivière
d'un côté l'épicerie la caisse et le
poste d'essence de l'autre l'aéroport et
lucky un aéroglisseur les revit l'eau
n'est pas profonde mais les vins sont
cruels et paralysent souvent le service
[Musique]
ce matin personne ne peut traverser pour
prendre l'avion qui va atterrir de
l'autre côté de la rivière
pour cette mère c'est un drame
pourquoi ici urgent pour vous traversez
il faut se rendre à l'hôpital à québec
pour que brown examen médical si son
bilan sanguin permet il subira un
traitement de chimiothérapie en suite on
espère qu'on aura un autre traitement
dans trois semaines et qu'après ça tout
se termine finalement l'avion n'a pas
atterri
car il n'y avait aucun employé à
l'aéroport tous retenus de l'autre côté
de la rivière
le lendemain nouvelle tentative de
départ l'aéroglisseur traverse cette
fois c'est l'avion qui se fait attendre
souvent sans devoir attendre l'avion à
cause du bon oui c'est ça arrive le lot
habituel météo ici c est triste bilan
le vol est annulé et plus
d'aéroglisseurs en service valérie
décide de retourner chez elle par ses
propres moyens à ses risques et périls
je sois encore l'hiver dernier deux
doigts sont venus un dimanche chercher
une pizza au restaurant du village en
retraversant pour rentrer chez eux ils
sont tombés à l'eau à moins 30 degrés
oui comme anne voyons c'est pas normal
de vivre ici en 2010 orange risque on se
demande ce qui est arrivé au pont promis
à catane existe depuis quatre ans et pas
de travaux en vue à la mairie on lui dit
n'avoir aucune information
et pas qu'à ta ne refuse de lui remettre
des documents affirmant qu'il n'est pas
soumis à la loi d'accès à l'information
des citoyens des scènes en gros on me
disait que ce n'était pas de mes
affaires et je me disais comment la
municipalité est un organisme public et
le gouvernement du québec idu vers ces
fonds à pakatan est un organisme public
comment se fait-il qu'on ne peut pas
avoir l'information aux espy
elle découvre alors que pakatan a
dépensé 40 millions $ et abandonner
l'idée de construire le pont et femip le
plus pour vous si une compagnie reçoit
une somme d'argent du gouvernement avec
le mandat de construire un pont le
cheminement
elle va construire le pont d'abord et
avant toi c'est pas ça qui est arrivé
pourtant il y avait amplement d'argent
pour construire le monde
où est passé l'argent versé à pâques
attendent sur les 100 millions annoncés
40 millions alors été dépensés entre
2006 et 2010 à cette époque
genivar fait les études sur le pont à
construire à cette auguste est la
priorité numéro un allemand de l'effort
dans la pièce le pont il n'est pas gros
feux baptisée fait un jour ça va
dépendre de la volonté du gouvernement
de faire un temps
au début pakatan veut commencer tout de
suite à construire les approches du pont
elle a même choisi une entreprise pour
se faire devancer des choses mais ça
nous a fait à gratter pour ducati on
vous n'avez pas honte de faire ça parce
que on sait tous que le pont vous ça
prend 10 est pour faire une étude pour
savoir ce que le prendre alors tombé
dans la réalité après les exigences du
ministère des transports et de
l'environnement de l'archéologie au
québec il ya à peu près acquise
le groupe demande ou de nuages qui
s'imbriquent t d dans la construction
d'une route à catane cette année passe
au franc ce pouvoir avec leurs 100
millions de bahts d'abord des coudées
franches
alors qu'ils se sont fait imposer une
gestion par le ministère des transports
donc ça a été vu par catane comme un
vrai qu il ya eu ce genre de polémique à
un terme à catane ministères vont piger
qui était le plus fort qui est des
greniers
c'est une saga grenier
le pont à voie unique pour permettre aux
villageois de passer d'une rive à
l'autre devient un pont national
au fil des études le coût estimé passe
de 25 millions $ à 57 millions quand tu
veux le projet n'importe quoi ouvert au
matin la valeur du point
[ __ ] tu veux pas faire un projet qui
piquent fait projet de contrecoeur ttt
pas intéressés à faire un projet ces
mystères que vous dites il faisait un
contrat-cadre à raconter tout et tout à
fait d'accord et tapas l'idée originaire
9 napo de dos tout reste en suspens
aussi corinne qu'est ce qu'on cherche à
savoir ce qui se trame
elle découvre une résolution de la
municipalité de gros mécatina celle de
randy jones le président de paca tan
qu'il demande de dépenser l'argent
plutôt pour désenclaver son village et
net
demain dans cette résolution la
municipalité de gros mécatina demandé au
ministère de retirer le pont de
l'entente avec macadam et de s'en
occuper lui même autrement dit il
demandait de nous retirer l'argent pour
construire notre programme année la
priorité numéro un était de penser non
il n'y a aucun autre un numéro tout
petit en priorité le pont de saint
augustin priorité aussi jusqu'au
téléviseur à genivar est en venu pour me
le dire qu'au lieu de coûter 25 médian
quand qu'on avait prévu ça coûte à 55
médias
sans en informer la population pakatan
décide d'abandonner le pont
les villages se déchire et l'insistance
de commandes jusqu'au dérange huit coups
ont été tirés la sqs team que cinq coups
auraient pu être mortelles
c'était un sérieux avertissement non
peut-être policière n'a pas trouvé de
suspect mais corey a pris cela comme une
menace
ici la balle est passée juste au dessus
de mon lit
si j'avais été couché je serais morte
robin dunne c'était un message message
qu'ils arrêtent de poser des questions
et cessent d'intervenir dans les
dossiers de paca talent
l'argent est investi ici à gros mécatina
sur cette route qui ne mènent nulle part
[Musique]
j'ai idée c'est une compagnie locale est
engagée pour la construction des routes
un contrat à l'heure ce qui est
inhabituel la machinerie est loué à baie
comeau montréal ou matane et apporter
ici par barge avant même que le contrat
ne soit octroyée
aujourd'hui elle rôle du parent milliken
tout cela coûte cher plus cher que prévu
le prix qu'on avait des entrepreneurs à
l'époque était de retour de lussan à
1200 km alors que là on dépasse deux
millions
exactement la route forestière négocier
en haut lieu se heurte à la bureaucratie
de ministère des transports nous on a
demandé un chemin forestier pour donner
accès puis un dernier jeu parce qu'ils
voulaient un autre route avec regardez
moi c'est plus qu'un chemin forest side
les travaux avancent lentement par
exemple le ministère refuse trois fois
les plans et devis pour les autres
kilomètres de cette route est ce que
c'est normal qu'une firme comme axa
quand même qui connut vu que
l'expérience se fasse dire trois fois de
reprendre les plans et devis au point
opaque athènes est obligée d'envoyer une
mise en demeure
non c'est pas normal mais dans un contre
et il ya des contrôles sur 30 contre au
congo il ya peut-être un contrat qui
vont moins bien
le bureau régional dirige tous mes
plaintes pakatan lorsque les choses
tournent mal
il refuse de payer certains travaux
alors qu'il avait pourtant accepté les
contrats il allait même que paca tonnes
à effectuer des paiements occultes mais
sans préciser malgré les demandes
d'explication temps additionnel le
ministère prenait toutes les décisions
tessi lui qui choisissait les
fournisseurs octroyé le contrat est
autorisée les paiements sur ip percuté
lundi de pâques à ça ne servait qu'à
signer les chèques qui ce n'était qu'une
marianne est l outil propre est lancée
par deux ministères et on n'était pas
capable d'aller aux armes de ben ça que
ça passe par le ministère je peux vous
soucier si davie éviter dont on ne
pourra rien faire ça que les ministères
du jeu oui car il disait sauter on
demandait quelle honte à meylan d'aller
montrer les priorités oui puis en q2 ses
priorités là qui est effectué par des
priorités à cause que le ministère des
transports takada n'a jamais été capable
d'adopter à villedubert bas
impossible d'avoir la version du
ministère des transports qui refuse de
nous accorder une entrevue
juin 2013 de façon abrupte ils arrêtent
de payer et même à catane en faillite
même les études sur le pont sont aidés
rompu alors qu'elles étaient presque
terminées vous pour le maire de
saint-augustin vous obtenez pas l'étude
finale concernant le pont dans votre
communauté donc payer l'argent public
la prochaine à le protéger le rapport
final n'a pas encore été fait non parce
que le projet roth pas été arrêté avant
après avoir dépensé des millions le
gouvernement refuse de verser les 30000
dollars nécessaires pour la terminer et
là c'est dans dix ans on décide de faire
le premier pas pour reprendre toute
l'étude probablement évident que si on
attend trop longtemps oui les conditions
vont avoir avoir changé tout ce qu'on a
dépensé que des environnements pour les
études va falloir prendre une grosse
partie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui malgré les 47 millions de
dollars dépensés légende à basse côte
nord sont toujours aussi jolie
un transport un avion ne serait ce que
deux villages à l'autre coûte plus de
800 dollars
et le bateau qui transporte marchandises
et personnes une fois par semaine va
suspendre le service cet hiver
[Musique]
nous sommes des québécois et des
canadiens à part entière on ne peut pas
être traités comme des ours noirs qui
berne tout l'hiver qui ressentent au
printemps lors ce qu'ils ont fait pour
que le gouvernement leur donne à manger
on ne peut pas vivre comme ça au québec
et au canada aujourd'hui cette
aéroglisseur a été installé à grands
frais il ya deux ans par la société des
traversiers du québec pour faire taire
la grogne des villageois
histoire de colmater le gâchis de l'
aventure de pakatan souliers de voyez
vous une solution pour l'avenir
non l'aéroglisseur vient juste d'entrer
en service n'ont pas leur place de sow
c'était ça la solution et on n'aura pas
d'autre avant longtemps attendez vous
encore le second mais moi non je pense
pas que ça va arriver
pas après avoir tant dépensé pour
l'aéroglisseur g
d'après moi
il va avoir la glace en enfer avec on
est une route où la basse côte nord
c'est une vraie honte parce que on
l'avait pour moi c'est tout ce que est
non je pense que c'est
c'est un crime contre les jambes de
agosto construire une route plus
rapidement et à moindre coût aura été au
pari insensé du gouvernement et de
pakatan le coût politique s'est terminée
un gaspillage de fonds publics et laisse
aux gens de la basse-côte-nord le
sentiment d'avoir été trahis
[Musique]